あれ？
はじめさん？
はじめーんのスマホやないかい！
融合！！！
ﾌﾞｩｩｳｳﾝ!!　ﾌﾞｳｳｳｳﾝ!!
ブンブンマサキマサキ！！！
あっ…
…あれまさき？
…まさきー？
んああああああ…（ため息）
やっぱ「融合」だよなー…
まさき：はじめさん…？
…え？
まさき：はじめさん！
…まさき？
まさき：ここだよここ！　気づいてくれよ！！
おいどこにいるんだよ…
隠れてないで出て来いよ？
まさき：はじめさんのスマホの中だよ…
え！？
うわあああああああああ！！！！（叫び）
…お前本当にスマホの中なのか？
そうなんですよ…
昨日、はじめさん家で転んで、気づいたらスマホの中に入ってて…
出れないの？
うん。
ぅうわぁああん…///
彼がスマホと合体してしまった原因は…
「融合」を踏んだことであると思われる。
はじめさんお腹空いたー！
ん？
早く電気をくれー！
ナ：まさきはご飯を食べる必要がなくなってしまった。
もぉおおう仕方ねぇなぁ…
ナ：彼は…スマホを充電することが、ご飯になってしまったのだ。
やめろよまさき！　おい！
ナ：お風呂は一日一回、台所で俺が彼を洗ってあげている。
涼しいだろ今日も…？
まさきがスマホと合体してから…
かなりの日にちが経ち…
俺たちは、この生活に慣れ始めていた。
一緒に公園に行くこともあれば…
一緒にメロンソーダを飲むこともあった。
まさきはスマホながらも…
鳩に餌を上げることも出来たのだ。
俺は彼がスマホだからって…
特別扱いせず、
一緒にドライブにも行った。
俺は、スマホになってしまったまさきが、
行きたいと思った所を…
どこでも連れて行ってあげていたのだ。
爺：頭オカしくなったんじゃおいー　ｳｯﾌｯﾌｯw
でも…
こんな事になるなんて思ってもいなかった。
アッハ…ｗ
そうだよなぁ、まさき！
まぁ結局！　お前もハンバーグが好きってことだよ！
うっはっはｗｗｗｗ
なぁまさき！
お前もこっちの生活、もう慣れただろう？
うん！　お腹減ったら充電すれば済むし快適！
あっはｗｗｗ
もうお前一生スマホの中でも良いかもな！
バカなこと言わないでよー！
まさき：ｳｯﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌwwwww
はじめ：ﾌｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊwwwww
はじめ：お前も言うようになったなぁ！
アッハッハッハ！！
あああああああああああ！！！
…まさき！
おい、大丈夫か！？
はじめさん！　来ちゃ駄目！！！
えぇっ…！？
まさきぃ…
まさきぃぃいいい！！！
スマホの中でも・・・
車に轢かれたら…痛いんだね…
バカ、これ以上喋んな！！
今充電を…！
うぅ…
…充電されない！！！
多分…ウルトラスーパーケーブルがやられてる…
…このままだとお前、死んじまうよ！！
大丈夫、はじめさん…！
iCloudに…バックアップは取ってあるから…
それでお前は助かるのか？
ごめん…
嘘だろ…？
スマホとして…
はじめさんと過ごせた時間は…
楽しかった……よ…
…ぉぃ、　まさき…？
まさき！！！！
まさきぃぃぃぃいいぃいいいい！！！
ばいばいきーん